yeah well i think hopefully the fans
will hear in this album that this is
the the art of song the songwriting the
songs that we wrote and recorded were
our way of
of really i think trying to just cope
with really uncertain months you know
and it was our way to really have a
creative outlet i think it was
therapeutic for all of us i think we
wrote a lot about just how we were
feeling about
a lot of things um i think when we you
know
the the whole album when it comes out in
october you'll get to hear i think some
some of the outliers of where we kind of
explored and took some risks um from a
song standpoint and production um but
ultimately i think it's just so present
for us and we are just so grateful the
reason why we named the album what a
song can do is because these songs and
the songs of our career have really what
have gotten us through
such hard times and then they've also
allowed for us the greatest times you
know in the live show and in all of the
years of of being a band so
hi guys congratulations hey how are you
good so
i have to ask about your tour mate carly
pierce obviously
big night for her big year for her
what's it been like for you guys to
watch her have all this success oh so
jealous i hate her
no we love her man she's she's
it's it's amazing i mean we feel almost
like
in a weird way i mean
like proud like for her i don't know
because we came out before her so i we
watched her become the star and so you
have this little proud parent thing and
especially having her out on the road
i know we're the seniors and she's the
citizens she's she's the junior coming
to kick us out of our spot
no we're super proud of her i mean she's
she's a star i mean she's a star and
then and tonight i think she showed that
um the two songs she's saying i mean
blew me away i was sitting there ashley
mcbride was geeking out behind me like
listening to her saying too and it was
really cool she i think she represents
our genre so well too i mean you know
her voice this style of country that
she's putting out there
her connections and love of the grand
old opry i mean we watch her every night
cover some old country songs and um i
don't know like her voice the texture
who she is and what she stands for i
think is so perfect to represent country
music especially on a night like tonight
yeah and i feel like when
you write
brutally honest music like she does
it connects it pierces to the heart of
people and i think that is what we're
seeing she's been so brave to write the
music that she's been writing and
releasing and i think that is what is
connecting so deeply with with all of us
because
it's real and authentic and
we've all lived our own versions of what
she's talking about and i think it
really connects on a deep level